Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm building a road through
the swamp in the interior of Alaska
because I bought an off-grid abandoned
Homestead equipment's been breaking down
we've been getting stuck in the mud and
buildings have been catching on fire but
we're not giving up
well it's been a couple weeks since
we've been here at the cabin I've been
waiting for good weather to dry up the
trail and we finally got it
we've got a lot of things to do at the
cabin we're gonna need the trail in good
shape to do it look at that the Grouse
right there
there's a whole bunch of them
there's dozens of them really delicious
game bird called a Spruce Head
it's time to check this out is that wolf
now look at the size of that
[Music]
all right guys Welcome to our off-grid
Alaskan Homestead we bought this thing
about a month ago and the previous
owners had walked away abandoning
thousands of dollars of equipment
including generators and ATVs and that's
a real common situation here in Alaska
most homesteads are miles away from the
road system so when it comes time to
sell you can't hire movers or back a
truck up
foreign
we got our first problem the generator
won't start because the starter battery
is dead the trickle charger that keeps
it full wasn't it hooked up properly
when we left last time so that's my
first mistake so far won't be my last
everything looks like it's in pretty
good shape
[Music]
there we go
whoa what
well I'm no expert but that's bad yeah
I'm not sure what to do with that
hey Tom
once you get that Jack out
dang it I think I need a socket wrench
set if I'm gonna do this and I don't
have one I'll have to put that on my
list of things to bring in from town
Tommy and Nathan have been working on
their own Homestead projects looks like
you guys got the playset up and running
everything I plan on doing today
requires me to haul in supplies with
that side by side
uh before the UTV broke number one on my
agenda was getting this Trail fixed we
still got these massive mud holes and
every time you drive through these
buttholes they just get deeper and
deeper I've got to fix these otherwise I
won't be able to get supplies in and out
of the property
whoa you see how deep the mud holes and
the ruts are
oh
all these Trails have the same problem
you use them too much and they get worse
and worse and worse
well we need to go head into town I
can't get much of anything done until I
get that UTV fix
Ed all right we made it
we're back and this time I brought a lot
of tools we are gonna fix this Trail
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go get the sleeping bags all set
up get your bed set up take a little
break then we're gonna go work foreign
I've got so many things to do around
here and all of it is made more
difficult by the fact that this Trail is
so muddy so my number one priority is
getting this Trail in better condition
the ideal way to fix all these mud holes
is to drain the water away and to fill
them up with rocks and gravel problem is
where do you get the gravel hopefully I
can use this excavator to find some
gravel
all this wet
this way this is the problem
but as soon as you as you vibrated it
turns into a liquid you get driving an
ATV back and forth on this thing and it
just turns into slop
I heard a nice crunching sound on that
last scoop
there's rocks in this
now I just need to get this stuff
and fill up that this mud is pretty soft
I mean you see you put rocks on it and
they'll just disappear down in there so
I'm gonna try to fill up these mud holes
full of wood and whatever else I can
find and then I'm going to put the good
soil on top of it
foreign
[Music]
thank you well this hole gives us a good
picture of what we're dealing with and
you can see we've got about two three
feet of this brownish muck and then
we've got this gray clay with lots of
rocks in it the fact that we got tons of
shallow groundwater is a big part of all
of our problems now this part of the
trail was in pretty good shape before I
started digging but just the movement of
the machine has caused these pretty deep
ruts to appear
foreign
there you go that's what we're trying to
do we fill up the mud holes with wood
and then we put good dirt on top of that
but until this good dirt dries I really
can't run the excavator on it so I think
what I need to do is lay down all my
wood and go to the very end of the trail
with the excavator and then work my way
back putting good dirt on top of the
wood Tommy you hungry yeah we'd like to
go make some dinner yeah all right let's
do it
you hungry you want some mac and cheese
yeah
all right I made Tang all right there's
there's a picture
is mac and cheese and spam the best
scooping up mac and cheese with a chunk
of fried spam
we forgot to bring glasses so we're
drinking communals paying
you guys like that
here I'll tell you what guys we got some
dessert here
are you gonna take these over the sea
all right this is uh confetti birthday
cake cookies here yeah that's I'm sure
that's healthy
yeah well you got some food in me and
I'm feeling like I can tackle this Trail
again
oh that is filling up quick
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I think I got a lot done today
all right guys you want a little
midnight snack
or early warm milk good weight or in a
bad day
there you go Nate
your bag put up your Pokemon cards all
right guys we've got to go to sleep
we're gonna put the camera down and I
will see you in the morning well good
morning it is a beautiful day outside
I'm gonna quickly eat some breakfast I'm
gonna get out and keep working you guys
want some strudel
it's not
all right let's see if the toaster works
oh it's working
they say the Alaska state bird is the
mosquito they're huge they'll bite you
through your clothes
spent last night tossing and turning and
thinking about how I was gonna get this
all done in time we got a lot done
yesterday
this is Rock Solid
and I could drive on this just as is and
it'd be great let's see what the clay
has done
it's only been about 12 hours and this
Clay is really firmed up a lot I give
this several days in the Heat and it'll
get pretty nice
how much water is poured in there so you
can kind of see what I'm doing here on
the really deep mud holes I'm putting
the logs sideways and I'm using really
thick logs and that's Bridging the Mud
Hole you can see when we get over to
this stuff the ground's not half bad so
I'm just taking logs and filling up the
ruts and I'm covering everything with
Limbs and branches and because I'm
laying it directly onto the soil I can
use smaller stuff and get away with it
you know and so far it seems to be
working okay but I'm worried about
running out of time so instead of
working linearly I'm going to hit the
biggest mud holes first and we're going
to work from there well we may be short
on time but we're not short on Deadwood
look at all this dead spruce
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
got a fair amount done but I'm hungry
I'm gonna go grab some lunch
what's going on in here
oh look at oh look the boys have been
picking some blueberries you want me to
protect these from Nathan yes I'm gonna
put them somewhere Nathan can't get them
oh no no no I'm sure he's just a ball of
sweat
here in Alaska we call this make it a
Corduroy Road Tommy you've been
blueberry picking yep yeah an hour worth
of blueberry picking not bad Tom
ah
this is the magic tool for chainsaws
that's the very last of my gasoline
[Applause]
but it is dinner time
oh that is not good all the water we
have left is in this tea kettle
oh
well we're almost out of water we're
almost out of Chainsaw fuel we're low on
snacks and food but the most frustrating
part is we brought it all it's all
sitting at the car we just couldn't fit
it all on the excavator I really got to
go fix the tracks on that side by side
oh
I'm working on this back wheel and I
look up and I noticed the front wheels
already derailed
look at that there's a tensioning nut on
these tracks that keeps the track tight
keeps it from falling off and it's set
to the wrong setting and it's rusted
that way and I can't get it to turn this
is a massive pain in the butt I think we
should just slap the tires on them what
do you think yep
Maybe
there you go stop it
[Applause]
as soon as I let off the starter it dies
this thing is being so frustrating you
need to put it in drive and spin the
wheels forward in order to take the lugs
off so we can't get the other tracks off
and we couldn't drive it even if we did
we need to clean this mess up
well the boys are exhausted and we've
got way too much stuff we need to carry
back to do it by hand so we're going to
take the excavator
come on hop aboard boy
[Music]
oh look at this big jug of water doesn't
that make you happy yeah it's basically
foreign
guys I'll see I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
do a little more work
love you bud
[Music]
oh man I built a lot of road today
but I've got to test it out
I'll tell you that corduroy works really
well
this part is Rock Solid no complaints
there
but this this is a bit sketchy
you're gonna see right about here
I got off track and just started digging
a huge rut you can literally see the
water starting to fill up in the ruts
it's like driving on a giant sponge well
it's pretty late
I think I need to get to bed
ah good morning
oh I'm a bit stiff I brought some of the
supplies from the cars
silverware
Oreos and a cutting board which I need
to clean off
[Music]
oh the generator just died and our
lights went out that tells me the
generator's out of gas
[Music]
you guys like that
yeah
wow look I got my hand back
oh crap that's on fire
oh bring the fire receiver
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
that's it for the fire receiversary no
no that's fine
good job getting the fire extinguisher
Tom
I was making pancakes I heard a little
bit of a popping crashing sound thought
a bear might be messing around with our
stuff so I poked my head out of the
cabin and I see smoke just coming out of
the generator cabin I'm like oh crap
well I'm guessing that's the real reason
the electricity turned off
oh hold on I got oh my God okay sir oh
I burned my pancakes
so I think it's pretty obvious what
happened the previous owners had scooted
the generator up against the wall so
that the exhaust would blow out of a
hole in the wall the exhaust overheated
the wood caught it on fire that caught
the generator on fire and that fire had
been burning in there for probably 15
minutes before I came out here and
noticed luckily the door was all closed
and so the oxygen couldn't let the fire
spread very fast
niche
all over here
look at that oh look at this melted the
light bulb
here we gotta check for Embers oh this
stuff's pretty hot
guys get out of here there's a lot of
toxic smoke so Smoky and hot up in the
attic I can't even breathe up there the
fire been going long enough to burn that
stud into that's crazy
foreign
there's still some fire in there dang it
yeah look at that still got Embers this
thing could reignite
[Music]
we got to keep our eye on this for the
next couple hours make sure there's no
Embers burning we don't want to fire
reigniting I've only got about maybe a
gallon and a half two gallons of water
left so we're in no position to fight
another fire
oh
yeah that's a hot mess no pun intended
I need breakfast
yeah that's
there you go that's a pancake for a man
that just put out a fire
oh
it's a lot easier to think about this
with a full belly
here why don't you guys go in there and
pull out anything that's burned pull it
out and make a big pile out here okay
oh yeah this Cherry's got a little
melted all right take that uh
melted this bin
here watch out
his Styrofoam insulation look it's all
melted keep an eye out for any
smoldering if you see any smoke or
smoldering you let me know okay on the
upside the boys are very entertained
just tore a nice hole in my jeans
turning out to be one of those days all
right we're gonna hop in the excavator
we're gonna throw some mud down
thank you
I've dug about five and a half feet down
and there's no clay no gravel just more
more loam there's this thin layer of
sand that I thought was gonna help me
out but it's only about two three inches
thick and I can't really dig down any
further because this big pile alone is
like jelly every time I dig down the
whole thing just Jiggles I'm gonna have
to find a different way to get some
clean gravel in here
gotta go return the excavator better
load it up with any supplies we need to
take back to the car
oh
hey look we got some guests hi Mom I do
hi did you bring us some food did I
brought you food and water Melissa did
you want to go see the cabin
ET I've been using this opportunity to
give Becca a tour of the property and to
carry 50 pounds of canned goods on my
back oh
God to get that side by side fixed
you can kind of feel that ground how
spongy it is
faint odor of burn generator on the Wind
how expensive yeah that's not that's not
cheap
I forgot we had like a whole bunch of
propane bottles and gas cans in here
glad those propane bottles didn't go up
hey you want to see the the part that
isn't burned come on in
all right
I'm sorry the lights aren't on we're
having electrical issues at the moment
so this is the The Loft up there oh
there you go babe
that's what I blew all of our money on
[Laughter]
you know I told you this was a good deal
because it comes with a working UTV and
a generator
well thanks for coming out and visiting
I needed a little cheer up Tommy you
going with Mom yeah me too you catch one
building on fire and they abandon you
like that
[Music]
thanks
oh yeah
yeah got about 50 60 pounds of canned
goods I brought back
need more canned spam
we were running low
I got some mixing bowls and a measuring
cup and some other odds and ends we were
missing
good
you know I was thinking about it the
generator is gone but why is the solar
power not working
solar panels look fine let's go see if
we can figure it out
it was so hot in here it could have
easily fried something in the
electronics
batteries are full but the inverter says
error well maybe it's just the fact that
my electrical system burst into flames
today but I feel like this is something
I shouldn't handle on my own I'm gonna
get a professional well it's times like
this you just need to focus and pick
some tasks that you can accomplish
just to keep your sanity
you know I don't think that hole is that
bad if I just hit the hardware store and
grab some tools I think I can fix that
pretty easily
I think next on my agenda is finishing
this Trail I'm like 85 percent done
[Music]
well I got a lot done but I need to head
into town I've got tools and equipment I
need and frankly I need a shower so it
looks like I'm gonna be coming back out
here tomorrow
probably
all right here is perfect
it's important to know when I'm in over
my head so I called the guys from all
off grid and bless their hearts they
came out here on a Saturday in 4x4 down
here to help me out and while we're at
it we're going to replace the golf cart
batteries with these two lithium
batteries so with just two of these I'm
gonna triple our battery storage in
about half the space additionally these
are Plug and Play So if I want I can
take this out with me charge it up at
home and bring it out and I can have
several days worth of power for each
battery
oh yeah oh wow yeah that voids the
warranty
they're like
how long would it take a generator like
this to charge those batteries up real
three hours three hours
well all those guys work on that I am
gonna try to see what I can do about
this
somebody left the ignition in the on
position yeah
oh the battery's completely dead we'll
add that to the list of problems
we might have power let's check this out
oh
look at that you don't appreciate that
until it's gone do you we got
electricity yeah thank you very much for
coming out I appreciate it I appreciate
it to you man bye-bye thank you
well that is great that we finally got
electricity again it's time to make some
lunch here
uh oh
that sputtering noise means the
propane's almost out
well it was six long hard days working
on this property and I feel like the
list of things I need to do is longer
not shorter but I still believe if I can
get this Trail in good condition every
other project will be so much easier but
for now I'm gonna have to cut this video
off and if you guys want to see what
happens next with this off-grid cabin
project make sure to click subscribe to
the outdoor Boys YouTube channel and
I'll see you guys at our next video If
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]